[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where we have with us mr
hawk hey
why are you shaking your head i i have
no idea well some kind of idea but
yeah nothing really crazy is gonna
happen you're basically on what uh these
guys like to call the hot seat where uh
you're just gonna get asked a bunch of
questions that are gonna start at very
cold temperature and they're gonna warm
up to being stuff that you probably
wouldn't want to answer but you have to
see like just watching the reels from jk
news it's definitely not yeah if i can
survive it you'll be fine
let's see yeah this might be the way i
go out like yeah
he sat on this channel that was it get
ready for a very british text from him
later asking can we please take that
down
perfect
in his accent
that's true hey anthony
hey just uh you know thank you so much
first of all travis however
however like double polite yeah
oh it's my anthony remember when you
said this
all right so we like to start off with
bart asking the coldest possible
question wait so how is it's just like a
question stop asking questions it gets
warmer and warmer we do questions focus
on answering you'll just get more
uncomfortable oh no yeah that's all oh
okay no edits this is live stream
so i'll start with a proper cold
question okay
punch him in the face if you had a
choice between replacing
your nose
okay
with two things yeah which one would it
be and the choices are yeah an anus
or a penis
and why kind of warm that's one of my
more favorite fun yeah that's a really
fun question so great accent penis i
just wanted him to say uh oh [ __ ] say
random words in there obviously yeah why
peter butthole uh closer shape i would
say you know
so
it would like it will feel the same if
you just like stretch your nose whereas
if it's a butthole it's going to be the
experience gonna be a little bit
different you really gotta kick it you
know you gotta go inside but don't you
think you could breathe better
no the butthole is like
you're probably gonna wait so it works
like a nose yeah is it just the shaft or
is there balls or something out of his
face it's just cosmetically look this is
cosmetics
[ __ ]
yeah it's just cosmetic so it still
functions like a nose yeah but one you
you can barely breathe because it's a
straw and the other one is a you could
throw
oh does the nose get hard tight nose oh
it's just limp yeah i think it's just
this is just like
okay i know it's still penis i mean
it's more fun too
just do this
i mean my brain's kind of doing the same
thing but i have double but can you do
that if your nose was a butthole no no
nothing what can you do yeah nothing
what can you do it smells like [ __ ] all
the time
i don't know if we asked this last time
but why did you come to america
sounds like someone wants you to go back
yeah you're a [ __ ] immigrant sorry
first of all boy is that a real question
i think so yeah we kick you redcoats out
dude
you [ __ ]
japanese and i'm american he's [ __ ]
uk and then i'm just like representing
that guy
we got you got damn red coach out of
here
oh you know well i i wanted to move out
from japan because at the time i was so
extra japanese
how do you become extra japanese it's
when you go to a japanese public school
and you never speak the uniform and then
did you look like that but your head was
all shaved and then you had the [ __ ]
sailor uniform i actually purposely
picked
studied really hard in to get into a
high school i think we only had one that
was in our area that didn't have uh any
like school uniform and you could do
whatever you want with your hair the
artist bro no but the thing is
what i didn't realize is that because it
was extra academic
no one had any interest in fashion or
style anything wow yeah so you sabotaged
yourself when you went into a nerd
school it was so boring i didn't have
any friends i know friends yeah but no i
honestly uh i was afraid i was going to
forget how to speak english so you were
in the uk for nine years nine years yeah
and then japan uh
about eight years after that
so you you most of your high school and
teen yeah yeah and then what made you
what made you go i need to get the [ __ ]
out of here and go to english-speaking
country
uh
i just didn't i
i think i slowly felt my english side
sort of fading you didn't make friends
with english speakers
no i mean they just weren't there's not
a lot of english i mean i feel like if
you go to international school yeah yeah
yeah but
the score happened to go to was just a
you know public school in our area and
there was no one i can relate to you
know everyone was born and grew up in
japan that's the hard part it's just the
way to go you know what are you the most
embarrassed about
oh i like this part what am i
most embarrassed about
um
that's a hard one
uh
i can give a bunch of ones
yeah help him out ryan
oh
um
i i uh i'm really really really bad at
sports and i can't if you threw me a
ball it's really hard for me to throw up
something right now
[Music]
the free laugh is ryan's reaction
he was like yes
yeah so i you didn't answer my question
how come how come wait wait
this wasn't how come you didn't watch
that
why why did you go back to uk where all
your friends were
and can go back to where you came from
instead of here that well that's exactly
the reason because when i had the option
of studying abroad going to england
didn't feel like studying it was like
just going back home i was studying at
home
dude i'll punch him in the butt
very very quick and efficient best and
worst thing about all three countries
best and worst thing about that's a good
question
uh best thing about japan uh
very unique they have their own distinct
culture
bad thing is that uh too many japanese
[Laughter]
uh they're very slow at
business i think oh really really so
slow i would think they're so efficient
no no no it's like certain things that
just like karate out here could be done
with one email it will take five
meetings like the first meeting is to
just have a meeting
the purpose is you know just battle for
40 minutes we're meeting we're meeting
we're amazing
english now
japan
hello
[Laughter]
good thing about england uh lots of
history um
just love that i feel like uh i don't
get too much of that out here what about
whoa hey
no i mean like
no you haven't seen bob's big boy come
on
all of our buildings are like 10 20
years old
you've never been to the world famous
las vegas
or old town pasadena come on dude that's
old old 80 years old
that thing about england
um
i don't know well i have a very biased
opinion because i just grew up there as
a child so my memory is kind of
during that did you like it though
growing up there i loved it well that's
that's all i knew you know we didn't
have
anything because that's true
everything's pretty awesome until you're
nine yeah that's true yeah no he's a
villager oh yeah no
no asian people at all you know really
that was a rule they didn't bully you or
anything like that he's like worst thing
about america asian people
he says
no i'm sure i don't know if it was bully
you know
it's funny though because when you look
back at pictures it's like why wouldn't
you make fun of that yeah because i
stood out so much and especially because
i was
extra tan for some odd reason
and everybody was jealous probably so
everyone thought japanese people were
tan
but it's like no
so did somebody go like who's your real
father
you're like philip you know what my dad
said
that's what that's what my father said
still yeah so put that on hold i'm not
sure about what's bad about england
circle back circle back uh america
good thing i love how diverse it is you
know this was uh
the first time in my life when i moved
here it was i was able to realize that
it's okay to be yourself you know
because there's so many cultures so many
religions beliefs ethnicities that the
way you look because before that
england was especially where i lived you
had you were just english and you know i
went to a christian school that was just
it there is no other ways and in japan
in tokyo it was the same thing everyone
was japan uh japanese and you just
you know think the same way and i
thought you had to fit into either or
they were really extremes
and then when i came out here it was
like oh
it's it's okay you know it doesn't have
to be that way that was like the most
positive thing i've heard about america
in like four years yeah it was nice and
maybe it goes yeah like it's not diverse
enough that made me go like yeah
america pasadena
he's got that pasadena prize they're all
right that's what i said nascar
so we're at the 10-minute
13 second mark of the video where we
start to turn up the heat and stuff like
that you know warm it up a bit
rumor is on the streets that uh your uh
your girlfriend's a little taller than
you his fiance this fiance
congratulations congratulations
not little very yeah just what's the
height difference
quest by the way
i don't know just okay
the real question i'm trying to get to
is like how is that
it's just you pervert
wait how much taller
you pervert
how tall are you
i'm
what five
five six five five four five with brown
eyes smile like the sunrise that's what
you want i actually don't know i don't
think she's six
she's six feet no no no she's not but
little yeah
five eleven five five twelve but if she
wear heels she's six oh she's six feet
oh really yeah yeah uh was she at the t
tj's birthday party
yeah i think so but you guys oh no no no
she wasn't sure oh she wasn't she was
working here no what's your real
question anthony what does doggy style
like yeah
when you hug dog style makes sense no do
you when you guys hug do you meet her
neck or her breasts
probably in between okay yeah can you
guys like 69 is it more like a 49
just one way 49
i mean i'm kidding i'm kidding that's
two warms
back it up we're friends but you can
answer it and then we'll edit it in the
way of it getting warmer
oh
well done so we'll reposition the
clothes i think now he wants the answer
do you have 69 or no
yeah you know
i was thinking i was like you do it
properly yeah it's normal but then what
are they called the uk i don't know why
it works
i guess today's video is brought to you
by feels cbd is not about what you feel
it's about what you do not feel such as
pain anxiety stress and all the icky's
in your bodies or sometimes it's when
you've been driving for four hours
because you're on crazy ass caffeine
because you know on the days that we
shoot here yeah as soon as i'm done
especially like the long days like we do
like three days i try to like pound some
caffeine and go straight home
and then so i i'm driving trying to stay
alive and then i get home but then when
i get home because i pound so much
caffeine my heart's like
oh man i need to go to sleep so i could
be well rested so that's why it helps
out to have some feels some couple drops
in my tongue
watch a little bit of tv get a [ __ ]
and then bam that's so nice yeah
and you know what's awesome is if this
is your first time you've never done cbd
fields has a cool little hotline you
could call and be like hey i'm kind of
embarrassed because i don't know how to
do this stuff can you help me out um how
much of a dosage should i take and
there's an expert on the other line
that's going to help you walk through
this whole process yeah and in case you
don't know what cbd does it helps
reduces some stress
anxiety some pain some sleeplessness so
if those are anything that are affecting
you in a bad way take some of this and
it just shows you right now yep just
take a few drops under your tongue and
just wait for it to settle in yep and uh
if you want to do their monthly
membership it's really convenient
because it just goes right to your door
and you get to save some money too very
good so start feeling better with feels
become a member today by going to
feels.com off the record and you'll get
50 off your first order with free
shipping that's f e a l s dot com slash
off the record to become a member and
get 50 automatically taken off your
first order plus free shipping
fields.com off the record it's like
maybe your torsos match yeah
maybe maybe it grows only when you do 69
and then it goes bad
but you don't realize that
you've got a big ding dong you maybe got
a big ding dong man british one huh the
[ __ ]
says dog because my ding dong don't
reach if we try to do 69 her heads like
down here i'm like oh man we gotta like
take turns or something
or maybe she's really bending her back
like that i don't know
yeah it's like this it's not like this
it's like yeah we don't match man oh no
maybe
i didn't even think about that that's
what he's like that means if she's lying
down she's like this and he's just
suspended
i love making this a move too
that's a move i think that's love can
just changes okay if you uh bad boys and
choreography if you had to kick somebody
off quest who would it be that's a good
question
that was a good one oh uh nikki t
yeah
who's nikki t see exactly exactly oh
[ __ ] why you laughing why you laughing
like do you agree we always use him as
that
like it's like he's on the crew just so
we have someone to say all right
so i'm gonna kick
who was your favorite quest crew member
that's so cute no no okay
okay let's say you two you can't say
anything right let's say you two were to
battle yeah
what move do you do that you think will
own his ass in the battle how do you
dunk on right yeah what's that what's
that what's that like weakness i know
ryan has and he can't do
this
i don't i don't think it's a move
yeah yeah i think um the only chance i
would have if it's a certain type of
music oh really yeah yeah music what
music what music
what's the music ryan can't do japanese
like your favorite japanese anime intro
i can't even do it japanese no because i
mean he has so many like blow-ups you
know
that i feel like battling normally
there's no thing dude like mike dropping
he has so many mic dropping moves yeah
yeah so it will have to be
i don't know a certain type that i could
i could actually go from like a more of
like a style angle
okay giant in-house one-on-one quest
battle who would be the top like three
people
in that order right in that order first
second third who'll be first second who
would win who'll be second place to be
third ryan don't say anything we're
talking about a dance battle yeah
dancing all night yes
all night all night dancing
all night long
the [ __ ] is
wow
yeah i don't even know who the two
people are
ryan subin brownie this ryan yeah yeah
this one
mike dropper
do you have any regrets
in your mind that you want to [ __ ]
share with the world right now go
oh [ __ ] with axe yeah what's your
biggest regret that you're like i
learned so much for this
everyone needs to know
like don't jack off with your left hand
when your mom's at home
throw your back out every time
it's it's a bit difficult because i feel
like
you wouldn't have yourself now if you
didn't have that regret i know and
that's the greatest answer because
everyone here does that but i just want
to find one day someone who always looks
in the past and just [ __ ] complains
all day about it yeah
[ __ ] i could find someone like that see
this is the
go get a
i wish i didn't murder that kid
quit bringing successful people on the
show
they all have the same mentality of like
my weaknesses make me stronger [ __ ] this
motivational [ __ ]
if quest could redo one moment in your
entire history what would it be
like redo it the same or
uh like anything and re redo it
differently are you hoping that they say
not winning
yeah because that's what they would say
i wish that we didn't win joe rather not
win
the most clever joke i've heard today
can you imagine if we did go back in
time and then we did it for anthony so
we purposely lose and he's all like yeah
what's the move you guys [ __ ] up on
just like a business move quest crew oh
like the whole thing yeah
it's not singular it's the entirety it's
not a business it's not a business at
all yeah
so you mean like just just the existence
of the quest crew was such a [ __ ]
mistake but you just no you're in it
good for what it was a hundred yes the
sickest lemonade stand
yeah yeah so that you can go all the way
you could go all around the world
have a absolute [ __ ] blast and it's
like people will constantly go up and go
why how come you guys only sell lemonade
we'll just go i don't know
[Laughter]
but because it's about to stand
people will be like yo
i [ __ ] loved your lemonade i when i
had it you know so right yeah
best lemonade i've ever had i'll be like
do you guys have any merch or something
we go
no but you can buy something
so you're saying like you could have
done so much more with it but you look
back and you're just like man we had a
lot of fun yeah i mean that was the
motive it was never really like oh let's
let's make build this business so that
it can go like this you guys aren't the
opposites yeah honestly
the business moguls and then the [ __ ]
court gestures like we'd rather do
business outside of quest and then just
always have it for what it is um that's
cool so it's like a sacred space in the
later years that's gonna win
i'd rather have that like i feel like
when you really look back like right
before you die
the stuff we did
it's amazing like you can't buy that and
you can only do it if you're that
irresponsible
at that point in your life too you know
yeah it's not like you can be wealthy
and you're 60 and you can do it you you
just can't unless you're richard branson
because he's just got so much money he
can hang glide at like 90 years old yeah
that gets
light at night you gotta you got the
worst gig you ever did where's job oh
yeah quest or not
uh
i think so yeah
uh it was the one tv show we did in
japan
yeah sadly and i think it was because i
was in a position where to japan i
wanted to kind of show what i've done
outside of japan and to
the coup it was with when we were um
traveling with lmfao i wanted to show
them how amazing japan was
but it was just
so badly prepped um
i think the communication between um
like the production and the artist was
absolute [ __ ] what came out of it was
horrible like the whole show was bad the
whole everything you guys yeah so what
was it a tv show it's a tv show and then
you got hired to just perform there
perform with the local like celebrities
yeah yeah yeah and they didn't know what
you're gonna do so we started doing
backflips they're like what it was it
was pretty [ __ ] i just remember that
they showed us a reference video and
they were like here's what the show
looks like and they sent us a video it
was like lady gaga was on there and it
was just decadent amazingly produced
thing and we were like holy [ __ ] we
could totally like kill the show and
then we went on there and they didn't
offer even one thing close to that level
of production for
our resources so what happened is you
guys came in and then the holes opened
up and you guys slid down and then got
dunked with slime
that would have been way better it just
made like a shitty ass like karaoke
video yeah but like it could have been
something like they they like did a
bacon switch and then i thought it was
gonna be also like abdc season eight
exactly exactly you guys didn't have the
five maintenance
the lead up to it no we did i think i
you know with the email i sent all these
requests but every one of them got
denied
and then i think at the end of it i was
like okay then i'll let go of the
control but i was hoping that maybe in
some magical crazy way they're really
good at editing that it'll make it look
amazing and end up still being [ __ ]
because it looks like because lmfo as a
as a whole like their shows are really
really [ __ ] good and well done and
combined with hawk like creating shows
for them it leveled up a lot but it
looked like they looked at it like lmfo
was still kind of a joke
like it hadn't occurred to them that no
we're already doing [ __ ] they're like
mega stars yeah yeah but they were like
oh like it's just like a funny joke
that's gone too far kind of thing what
that's mine probably
good job this is a funny the tough thing
is you know their main purpose was to
just tie the local artist and us up
so promo wise it still got the effect
sure yeah you know so that's the tough
line where it's like you got the shows
and i remember how mad he was too
because we were all like gathered to
watch it and he was just like what the
[ __ ] is this it's just so embarrassing
it's so so embarrassing you know
not even just artistically but i think
just my entire existence of being
japanese it like that's why it it was
like a harder hit to me and it was just
like these look like they didn't respect
us like yeah
he didn't tell him like let me just take
a thousand pictures of this and i'll cut
every single thing and i'll make them
all one so
that would be way better and then
there's going to be a copyright on
instagram to take down the art
no still not up yet just end on a better
note than that last pissed off
performance gig question um
uh
when was uh
the last time like ryan pissed you off
the most that's what you want to end on
just like the most [ __ ] up thing he's
done or just something embarrassing
anything unless somebody pooped
oh you want to end with something nice
yeah that is kind of nice it's nice for
our fans it's really bad nice for
anthony and kendrick's
because i'm over here trying to promote
because it's still it's still changes
for his quest 2022. it'll never end and
never
i don't know has that ever been the time
it was like
where you were like really mad at me
pretty like sean i said you're perfect
uh
no wonder he left japan he's not angry
enough but even if we went back like but
it's still not that bad
i don't know man
yeah ryan's awesome yeah no i mean
remember that one time we watched each
other's cars and then it was like
wonderful and we was trying to get mad
but we couldn't